well the russia investigation has been
going on for quite some time now and so
far it hasn't proved any of the
allegations that gave birth to it in the
first place but if you'll remember back
to the beginning
all of this was justified in part by the
publication of a dossier a totally
unverified dossier fill with salacious
allegations about Donald Trump and many
others in his orbit one person who was
targeted was a man named Alex gubarev
and his company xbt holdings the dossier
claims that xbt assisted in the hacking
of the Democratic Party leadership now
gubarev who denies this is shooing
BuzzFeed for libel for releasing the
dossier with his name in it now scoober
evan is attorney valgar bats join us
tonight thank you both for coming on so
thank you Alex you're denying of course
that you played any role in the hacking
of the Democratic Party tell me how the
inclusion of your name in this dossier
has affected your life and your business
Amanda's up you know one day you move 16
years ago out of her you start to your
business in European Union the United
States and you work so hard to be
company from scratch and you have
hundreds of employees who walk over you
their family depends on you and one day
you just wake up and sees that somebody
is in repetition and try to destroy your
business by telling the criminal that
you did some check against Democrats the
democracy in the United States and
imagine that like you have to explain to
your grandmother that you don't you're
not creepy now because she news about
your television you have to explain and
although you have a daughter's you have
to explain to your 17 years old
daughters that we are not the criminal
because she sees in the news as this
affect me and on multiple layers you
cannot even imagine yeah I still have
this pressure every day and I fight it
on every level so did you do anything
that was alleged in the dossier did you
have any role in stealing information
from the Democratic National Committee
servers do you work for Russian
intelligence
have you taken orders from Vladimir
Putin to destroy our democracy of course
not
I did what do you think why do you think
your name was in this dossier it's a
good question and honestly I don't know
and I hope that oh called kcv shame do
now again the bus hit and again please
the field steel in the United Kingdom
will help me to find out the answer on
this question mr. Gruber's have you
received any call from the special
prosecutor's office summoning you and
your client in for a conversation with
the Mahler team we have not and in fact
at the beginning of this lawsuit mr.
Guber have made it clear that he is
willing to cooperate with any
law-enforcement agency notably no one
has contacted us which tells us that at
least the law-enforcement agency does
not take the allegations against Alex
seriously but he no one I'm wait no one
has conscious we've had a couple
different Russia investigations going on
for more than a year your clients name
is in the dossier that forms the basis
of these allegations and nobody has
called you nobody has called you no one
not a single person has called them this
is the only person in this entire sordid
story that has gone on record to be
willing to speak to anyone under oath
and has given testimony under oath
unlike printing on everyone else that
that has been dodging depositions we
were still we just completed Christopher
Steele's deposition in London last week
he ran out of Appeals but he certainly
fought hard not to give one fusion GPS
is still fighting us I think they'll be
unsuccessful then they will have to give
evidence but there are certain certainly
trying hard to avoid giving evidence and
and so very quickly we're almost out of
time but did you get to the bottom of
how your clients name wound up in the
steel dossier do you have any idea we do
not we still have have not found a
single iota of
for him to be there but we're digging
we're continuing to look and we hope
that at the end of the day we will find
out
and yet this dossier is turned our
country upside down okay